welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as we wait for one division to
soon launch marvel's phase four
we just got a small but pretty crucial
clue explaining
how exactly marvel will probably
establish mutants and the x-men in the
mcu
and not the details we've talked about
before you know with one of max moff's
children in one division believed to be
the marvel mutants wiccan and speed
but the scarlet witch herself her cells
containing the mutant x
gene from the very beginning very
beginning
this reveal comes to us from the new
marvel in universe book the wakanda
files
this thing's filled with new canonical
mcu details compiled from shuri's
research
and buried in shuri's slam book is a
page on wanda
and how freaky her body is shade that
goes all the way back to the events of
age of ultron
filling in the gaps of the timeline in a
way that tells us
marvel's secret x-men plans going
forward spoiler warning in case i'm
right
and before i continue thank you to
privacy for sponsoring this video to be
able to get
five dollars off your first purchase
online with one of privacy's virtual
cards go to privacy.com
new rockstars okay so shuri's wakanda
files contain a section on hydra's human
enhancement experiments in sekovia first
shown in the post-credits scene of
captain america winter soldier to set up
the opening of avengers age of ultron
what we have is worth more than any of
them ever knew
we've only scratched the surface center
already
the twins sooner or later they will meet
the twins it's not a world of spies
anymore
not even a world of heroes this is the
age
of miracles doctor
there's nothing more horrifying than a
miracle
as i say the twitter handles with a
string of numbers at the end of their
name
you got blocked the way that the
maximoff twins were featured in age of
ultron was a little awkward at the time
due to disney's then licensing issues
with x-men characters
with fox which was then a separate rival
studio but now that disney owns fox and
soon our minds
marvel studios is now able to reach back
to scarlet witch and quicksilver's
origins
and retcon certain details specifically
the fact that both characters
are mutants in marvel lore the children
of eric lyncher
magneto all details that marvel used to
be legally restricted from referencing
at
all using terms like enhanced in place
of mutant
these wakandaphiles are the latest major
step
in clarifying what the age of miracles
really meant
a passage on wandamax moth describes the
ways the mind stone from the scepter
ionized her nervous system but it also
mentions that wanda and her brother
were chosen for these experiments for a
reason
and uh by the way thanks to our discord
pi annie badani for helping me track
down this stuff
apparently hydra settled in sokovia
because
the people of sokovia tended to display
genetic
anomalies that made them perfect test
subjects
pre-existing conditions or i should say
pre-existing
mutations genetic predispositions
making at least these two twins
naturally fit
four dangerous infinity stone triggered
experiments
that von strucker hinted most other test
subjects did not survive
the dead will be buried so deep their
own ghosts won't be able to find them
so what these files now confirm is that
one of maximos powers didn't just come
from the mine stone's gamma radiation
alone
but that the mind stone activated a
dormant
genetic code that was already there
since birth
in the marvel comics this genetic code
is called the x
gene the dna profile shared by every
mutant
making them distinct from humans that in
some cases don't get activated until
like hormonal changes in their teenage
years
so in wanda's case the ap chemistry
equation would be
the dormant x gene plus the catalyst of
cosmic radiation
yields powers and that would explain why
wanda's children whether they're real or
illusions would also possess mutant
abilities
like that scarlet glow we spotted on the
baby's hand and the wano vision trailer
inherited from their mama but what i
love about this wanda wanna wakanda
files confirmation
is how it links with other elements we
have seen throughout the mcu already
that could all collectively reveal
mutants as already existing in this
world
but before we continue this video was
brought to you by privacy one of our
partners has been kind to sponsor us all
this time
and something i use literally every
month it is awesome
privacy lets you buy things online using
virtual cards
instead of having to use your real cards
it protects your identity and bank
information on the internet and it's a
special treat for you guys new customers
will automatically get
five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now see with
this holiday shopping season upon us
you gotta make sure those grinches steal
your information or
overcharge you there's no room in
whoville for that kind of nonsense
see what i really love about privacy is
it comes in handy with the streaming
services i'm subscribed to everything
video conferencing apps other
subscription services i've set up an
account with privacy i link my bank
account and then i create a card
specifically for
say a monthly netflix subscription
payment privacy will ding you if someone
tries to charge the card twice
or if the card exceeds the amount you
set for it that way you only stay
subscribed for as long as you want to
stay subscribed for and when you
inevitably forget to cancel your
subscription it's okay you are covered
fill out your credit card info in the
privacy.com chrome and firefox extension
and then you're only ever one click away
from spending smartly and safely
privacy protects your identity and bank
information on the internet and
lets you control the limits on each
virtual card you can connect directly to
your bank account with confidence no
vendor can overcharge you beyond the
limit that you have set
it's simple it's fast it's just one
click head to privacy.comrockstars sign
up for an account and it's a special
treat for you guys
new customers will automatically get
five bucks to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only that is
free money folks just go to
privacy.comrockstars and sign up now
okay so it's interesting to learn that
there was something unique about sokovia
that led to hydra to choose it as a
testing ground but that doesn't mean
that there's like something in the water
that makes it a geographic anomaly for
mutant cabbage patches
it could just mean that this region on
earth was better faster and more
efficient at identifying people who have
this mutant gene
when those people really exist all over
the world and that this specific
sokovian region
could have made that information
discoverable by hydra for them to take
interest in it and sokovia would be
remote enough and politically unstable
enough for
hydra to set up residents to experiment
on those mutants but these places could
be
all over the world we just don't know
about it like another example we could
see in the mcu is that mysterious
detainment facility
and black widow that alexis shostakov
the red guardian is breaking out of that
appears to be somewhere in siberia and i
have speculated the possibility that
among alexi's inmate neighbors
could be russian mutants like peter
rasputin colossus
i mean someone busted that door down
doesn't necessarily have to have been
red guardian
and this age of miracles might have been
something occurring in the u.s mainland
right under our noses
many times in the past i've pointed out
that secret shield
project mentioned in an iron man 2 scene
i need some stuff out of storage
give me everything from projects pegasus
exodus and goliath with projects pegasus
and projects goliath now identified that
leaves only the mysterious project
exodus as
the unidentified program which i think
could be an mcu version of
weapon x similarly there was the deleted
alternate version of the nick fury
post-credits scene and iron man that
mentions mutants
already existing in this universe as if
gamma accidents
radioactive bug bites and assorted
mutants weren't enough
ant-man the wasp also hinted at a
possible molecular origin for this
genetic evolution with jenna van dyne
describing the
unusual process by which she acquired
healing powers
during her time in the quantum realm
adaptation is part of it but
some of it is evolution perhaps those
quantum particles gather
in large enough clumps within certain
individuals dna
to amount to a dormant x gene in a small
percentage of the population
a gene that would just need a catalyst
of an infinity stone caused a blast of
gamma radiation to activate
and that is why in so many past videos
since endgame came out i had been
speculating that one of those four snaps
of the six infinity stones in infinity
war and in game that released
universe-wide gamma blasts could have
been that switch
or all four could have been switches
that triggered the
x gene within mutants all over the
galaxy
think about it we got thanos's first
snap in infinity war the second snap
when he destroyed the stones
a third snap by hulk to bring everyone
back and a fourth snap by stark two
destroyed thanos forces but that second
snap had a particular description from
rocket
when dano snapped his fingers earth
became ground zero for a power surge of
ridiculously cosmic proportions no one's
ever seen anything like it
until two days ago
on this planet yeah look at that rainbow
shockwave you mean to tell me that a
blast of radiation like that
only had the effect of turning half of
everyone in a dryer lint if it
charred a thanos it stands to reason
there were other side effects so again
i think that x gene plus radiation
formula is how it's gonna work
mutants could have existed before the
snap in small numbers like with a small
subset of folks whose x genes were
awoken by random cases of extreme
radiation and that could have been what
led to hydra in sokovia in project
exodus if that is what it really is
but those numbers are about to go way up
after four big wake-up calls
yes oh and by the way if you want to
support this channel and get some
amazing apparel and accessories for
yourself or for a gift
for yourself check out our new merch
store at newrockstarsmerch.com
there you can find our custom
mandalorian this is the way shirt which
is selling out oh great looking hi i'm
eric voss shirt there's lots of great
options
check that out subscribe to rockstars
hit that notification bell follow me at
ea boss follow me rockstars thanks for
watching
boom
[Music]
you